ever since Apple's M1 ship disrupted the
laptop Market self-proclaimed M1 Killers
have been popping up all over the tech
industry but two years later that
couldn't be further from the truth and
the M1 killing idea is looking even more
Bleak for the future and in this video
I'm gonna prove it to you so let's get
started back on November 10th of 2020
Apple unveiled the M1 chip and back then
there were a lot of doubters but they
all ended up being wrong because the M1
ship was absolutely amazing and we know
that for sure because as soon as they
were released Max sales started
skyrocketing in January of
2021 and then another year later it was
shown that 2021 Max shipments grew twice
as fast as overall PC shipments but it
doesn't stop there because in October of
2022 the PC market got absolutely
slammed in the third quarter but Apple
instead saw massive Mac shipment growth
just look at this chart right here where
everybody is negative but apple is still
positive
40.2 percent growth and that's all
because of Apple silicon and of course
the new M2 Chip that we now have and
here is where Qualcomm enters the chat
because they purchased a company named
nuvia which was started by X Apple
Engineers which actually worked on Apple
silicon so supposedly they were going to
be able to make a chip that beats the
Apple m one the CEO said in July of
2021 and then again in November they
said it once again saying that they're
gonna beat apple with better sustained
performance and battery life they wanted
to be the industry leaders which I
personally was doubting and then things
started to look a little bit Bleak
because Qualcomm delayed those ships
saying that the first consumer nuvia
devices would only hit in late
2023 which is much later than their
original estimate and even on top of
that to add to the salt on the wounds
Qualcomm said that they will beat
Apple's M2 chips that was two days after
WWDC when Apple revealed the M2 Chip
with the MacBook Air the CEO said they
would even beat the M2 Chip with the
help of former Apple Engineers but guess
what ended up happening we just got an
update last month saying that qualcomm's
Apple M1 slash M2 rival is finally on
the way but qualcomm's new Chips won't
be in devices until
2024 yes they delayed it again and those
nuvia chips aren't coming into consumer
PCS until 2024 I can't believe they
deleted once again now the crazy thing
is Apple's M3 chip yes their M3 is gonna
be launching late next year late 2023 in
devices already before the nuvia chip
that's supposed to come and beat the M1
and M2 which is only launching in 2024
which I see as an embarrassment because
this M3 Chip is going to be on tsmc's
three nanometer chip process and it is
going to be incredibly powerful much
more powerful than the M1 and the M2 and
then here's where we get into an even
bigger issue what does beating the Apple
M1 and M2 even mean does that mean
benchmarks does that mean real world
performance because Qualcomm recently
released their sq3 chip in the Surface
Pro 9 and let me remind you that this
was once seen as a M1 MacBook Pro killer
Yes people were speculating that the sq3
would destroy the Apple M1 chip but
check this out we just did a 2022 iPad
Pro versus Surface Pro 9 comparison
video and the results are downright
embarrassing the first thing I want to
point out is that the starting price for
the Surface Pro 9 with the sq3 chip is
1300 the same as the iPad Pro M2 with
the same RAM and storage configuration
and let me remind you that that's
actually more expensive than the M2
MacBook Air so yes this is an expensive
device but let me show you the
performance as you can see in single
core the M2 Chip absolutely destroys it
it's about 80 percent faster but then if
we go over to the multi-core the M2 is
50 faster so yes it is a lot faster but
it might not seem like that big of a
difference but wait until I show you the
real world performance differences check
this out I ran speedometer 2.0 which is
a web browsing Benchmark and it
basically just shows you how Snappy your
device is for browsing the web and using
web-based apps check this out the M2
iPad Pro got 380 points or runs per
minute and the brand new sq3 chip in the
Surface Pro 9 only got a hundred and
three so the M2 is almost four times
faster in real world web browsing
performance not 50 four times and then
going over to a real World 3dmark
Wildlife Extreme Gaming Benchmark the
graphics performance on the M2 is over
two times faster I don't know what
Qualcomm has been doing for so many
years working on this sq3 because it is
just not impressive but wait until I
show you Adobe Lightroom photo editing
and how it performed first of all it was
glitchy glitchy as attack in real world
look how long it's taking to load these
images up but when I exported them look
at this difference the Surface Pro 9
took over six times longer than the M2
to export 50 raw 42 megapixel photos
over six times longer and it's
embarrassing because it's been two years
since the M1 came out and the M2 isn't
that much faster than the M1 obviously
even the M1 would beat out the Surface
Pro 9. and Microsoft even discontinued
the Surface Pro X because the sales were
just so bad and they gave you the choice
of either Intel or the sq3 chip probably
because they knew it is not a great ship
even compared to the previous generation
but the biggest issue is that the
service pro 9 with that ship is very
expensive thirteen hundred dollars now
imagine how expensive that brand new
nuvia chip is gonna be because they've
been working on on that ship for years
and they still have a couple more years
to go so they have to factor all of that
R and D cost into the price of the nuvia
chip so those chips are going to be very
expensive and honestly I doubt that
they're going to be able to beat the M3
but the even bigger problem with all of
this is that even if nuvia comes out
with an absolutely killer chip that
actually does beat the M3 chip we still
have the problem of Windows on arm which
is what the Surface Pro 9 is running on
and the reason it's so slow is because
Windows under arm is not nearly as
optimized as iOS and Mac OS is with
these new Apple silicon chips so even if
they match up in terms of benchmarks
which I don't think they will I honestly
don't believe that they'll get anywhere
close in terms of real world performance
in web browsing and actual productivity
app workloads and now pivoting over to a
different side of the market we actually
have Intel which is making some very
interesting moves they just announced
that by 2030 they will be the number two
Foundry in the world and they're also
embracing x86 arm and risk five it's
their multi-isa strategy so I believe I
personally believe that Intel is going
to be manufacturing Apple's Apple
silicon chips in the future as well as
all of the other chips and I think
they're specifically mentioning arm and
risk 5 because they know that the only
way the PC market specifically laptops
the only way they're going to compete
with apple is if they switch over to
these arm and risk 5 based designs
because x86 simply uses too much power
right now now the worst thing for Intel
is that they actually did have a chip
that was supposed to beat the M1 it's in
their roadmap but but they have
unfortunately been delaying it because
at first it was supposed to be ready to
ship in the fourth quarter of 2023 which
is when the M3 is supposed to come out
but they keep delaying it check this out
into a postpones production of meteor
Lakes three nanometer GPU tile at tsmc
which they were gonna use but they
delayed it so now tsmc is forced to slow
three nanometer expansion because of the
Intel delay and then Intel ended up
denying meteor Lake being delayed to
2024 and they updated it walking back
part of their debunk and check out what
just happened last month Intel has
delayed meteor Lake until
2024 so just like nuvia and the other
Apple M1 killers they keep delaying
their chips while apple is smoothly
sailing going over to M3 on three
nanometer later next year so the point
of all of this is that I think all of
these M1 killers are so behind that
they're not going to be able to catch up
for years and now finally it's starting
to make sense why apple is kind of
taking it slow and why they're probably
not going to rush into three nanometer
next year with the M2 Pro and M2 Max now
that really pains me to say that because
everything should be set in stone for an
early 2023 or at least spring 2023
release of three nanometer chips but
because they're so far ahead and because
everybody is delaying their Champs Apple
can simply sit back delay three
nanometer and be absolutely fine with
these stop Gap five nanometer or even
four nanometer chips because everybody
is so behind that apple is still beating
everybody else out in terms of
performance and efficiency especially in
terms of battery life in their laptops
so with that said I'm sorry M1 Killers
but I think that you will never come out
at least for the next few years we
probably won't be seeing any N1 killers
and apple is going to stay on top of the
laptop industry for years now if you
totally disagree with me then let me
know down in the comment section below
but if you're interested in buying one
of the M1 or M2 MacBooks you can check
it out using the YouTube product tagging
feature below click that Circle about to
subscribe check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
thank you